Okay.
Hello everyone. We are live.
We have a few things today. First of
all, I want to pull some experiment
results.
Um and then after that
We're going to take a little bit more of
a look at some of the CUDA code.
Depending on the results of these, we
might have to launch a few more. We'll
see.
Hello.
Welcome.
Um so this is
We're just started up the dev stream for
the morning.
I'm currently going to pull up the
results of some experiments to see if we
got anything reasonable overnight.
And then we're going to be working on
cleaning up the CUDA back end.
Like cleaning up some CUDA code for this
project.
One moment.
This will be quite obvious in a second
here.
I don't like the startup time being this
long. Okay, cool. So, here we have
constellation.
I don't know if this has learned
anything.
Yeah, see this did better than before a
little bit, but it's still quite bad.
Why actually I'm confused as to why
why are none of these better?
I would have expected at least a few of
the runs to have been
you know, quite a bit better.
As yeah, I still don't understand in
this case why our longer experiment
didn't produce anything reasonable.
Oh, actually, I wonder if it skipped
them.
Hang on. I wonder if it skipped them.
This could just be um
Yeah, hang on. This could just be
something dumb.
What happens if these ones that we're
skipping are precisely the logs we need?
>> I actually don't know if this will work
if this will break it either.
Let's see if this gives us anything
better.
I find it very weird that we don't have
good points at all in this.
Like at least a couple of these initial
ones have given us more, no?
And that was correct.
Hm.
>> [laughter]
>> Turn a grade. Ruined my grade by
streaming one day before econ exam.
Study for your damn exam, dude.
Okay, so yeah, this is just there are no
good data points. Cool.
Um why the hell are there no good data
points?
Would be my question.
Let's go take a look at our longer run.
So, I did get this one.
See, this is still not a good run. It
gets to three, 2.5 score.
Okay, so here's the thing, right? It
doesn't actually take off for like 10
bell steps.
How stupidly big would it be if we just
un like unrolled this whole string?
Is that like insane if we unrolled this
whole thing?
>> I have
dumb cloud over on the side to try
something for us
>> See, I don't want to change the config
of the end until we know that it's
matched.
Okay.
I mean, do we something with this?
I'm just trying to see how slow cuz the
problem right now is these experiments
are all super slow
cuz the cons network sucks.
Uh I'm I don't want to spend a bunch of
time on cloud crap.
But this is a super quick way to just
test this.